انا اسمي احمد محمد خطاب الزقزوق في صف
سادس عمري 11 سنه ساكن فخان يونس عند شارع
خمسه يوم الجمعه
151 كنا قاعدين نتغدى سمعنا صوت جنود
بينادوا على بعض بعدين سمعنا صوت واحد
بخبط بعدين سمعنا صوت انفجار وصارت تطلع
دخل من تحت
الباب ودخل عل اليهود وابوي كان رفع
الرايه البيضاء طخو طخ
امي واخوي وقع من ايد امي وجت القنبله في
عينه تفجرت عينه وبعدين رموا القنبله في
نصنا اليهود صاروا يحكوا معنا بالعبري
قلنا لهم احنا احكوا معنا بالعربي احنا
مدنيين صاروا يحكوا معنا اطلعوا معكم ع
ثواني بعدين فجروا الباب وقعدوا يشرحوا
يشلح الرجال و طلعونا بره ودونا على دار
الجيران وبعدين اخذوا عمتي حققوا معها
واخوي خلوا الكلاب يشمشم وه واخوي الصغير
شلحه اواعي
فتشوه جابوني في غرفه لحالي وجابوا الكلاب
وشمشم فيا وانا كنت خايف من الكلاب احقق
معان من الظهر لان المغرب سابونا قبل
المغرب خلونا نمشي ومشي
ومشينا صلاح الدين
جنوب لقينا ثلاث دبابات صاروا يرموا علينا
قذائف فغيرنا الطريق احنا مش عارفين وين
بنمشي لقينا دار مهجوره نمنا فيها ولما
طلع الصبح راحوا الدبابات
ومشينا ولقينا ناس و وخليناه يدلونا على
الطريق لحديت ما وصلنا مستشفى غزه
الاوروبي اخوي طول الليل يعيط عشان عينه
بتوجعه كنا عايشين منيح ابوي كان يحب
دايما يطبخ وكان تم دايما تجيب لنا العاب
ونلعب لعبه صياد السمك ونلعب كلنا مع بعض
وقصص ونحضر فيلم وبابا يعمل لنا فشار
ويجيب لنا شيبسي نقعد كلنا مع بعض لقيتها
في المستشفى غزه
الاوروبي
عايشين بنساعد في اخويا اخوي من ذوي
الاحتياجات الخاصه وماحدش بقدر له غير امي
وابوي واليهود
طخو وناس الليتر امي وابويا انا بكرههم
كثير ان شاء الله تخلص
الحر الله